- Here to look at these kittens.
But am I nervous?
Yeah, I'm fucking nervous.
- Like if a cat was big enough
it absolutely would eat you.
- I'm beyond excited to meet a kitten.
- Uh, they don't bother
me, I don't bother them.
- Don't like cats.
- I might be allergic to cats.
I know that I'm allergic to cats.
- So, I'm gonna go visit the incubator
where the cats are hatched.
- Here we go.
It's so little.
- You want me to take two?
Two or one?
- Oh my.
- They're doing it.
- There are three small children cats.
Child cats.
- Ah, I like this one.
- You got anymore of
these little loves of joy?
- Do you need my help?
I'm feeling...
Feelings of...
What I can only describe
as maternal protection.
- Reminds me of Stalone in Cliffhanger.
- I feel like a mommy.
I take back all the really
mean things I said about cats.
- Am I a changed man?
Yes.
- It could have been worse I imagine.
I was a little skeptical at first.
Well uh...
You want to get down?
- This is, it's pretty adorable.
I don't know, I mean, I can see myself
getting a little kitten like this.
They're pretty cute.
- I felt something.
- Uh, this has been a mind
changing experience for me.
I really have changed my mind about cats
and you should adopt one.
- I'll be fine.
- I feel like if you like raise them
and they'll just love you forever.
Look at this little guy.
He's just...
- This is the tool for the job.
You must learn to hunt little ones.
If you're ever to survive on your own.
Oh!